في لبنان اعلن حزب الله انه نفذ عمليات ضد
مواقع اسرائيليه قباله الحدود الجنوبيه
للبنان وقال الحزب انه استهدف تجمعين
للجنود الاسرائيليين في محيط ثكنه ميتا
ومحيط موقع جل العلام وقصف بصواريخ بركان
ثكنه برانيت كما استهدف مواقع المطله وحدب
يارون وبركه ريشه في المقابل افاد مراسل
الجزيره بتعرض محيط بلدتي كفركلا وديمي
ماس جنوب لبنان لقصف اسرائيلي
في الاثناء اعلنت اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي
اصابه جنديين بجروح طفيفه جراء قصف لحزب
الله اللبناني على قاعده برانيت العسكريه
في الجليل الاعلى وكان الجيش الاسرائيلي
قد قال في بيان انه رصد الليله الماضيه
اطلاق صواريخ او اربعه صواريخ من لبنان
باتجاه بلدتي سعسع في الجليل الاعلى وشومر
في الجليل الغربي وقصفت مدفعيته مواقع لبن
تحتيه تابعه لحزب الله في جنوب لبنان
معنا من بلده رميش جنوب لبنان مدير مكتب
الجزيره مازن ابراهيم ومن الجليل الاعلى
مراسل الجزيره امين درغامي مرحبا بكما
مازن ابدا معك واخر المعطيات على
الارض نعم في الواقع سلمى اي قراءه لواقع
الجبهه الجنوبيه للبنان اذا ما ارتكز فقط
على تعداد العمليات التي ينفذها وحزب الله
وما تقوم به اسرائيل فان هذه القراءه
ستكون قاصره عن الالمام بتطورات الحيز
الجغرافي الذي يحصل هنا تحديدا عند هذه
المنطقه الجنوبيه وعلى طول هذا الحيز الذي
يبلغ نحو 120 را لانه وفق كثير من
المحللين فاننا نشهد خلال منذ ايام مجموعه
من الرسائل الناريه التي يتم تبادلها بين
الطرفين ويجري الحديث حاليا وفق خبراء عن
رسائل بالشيف العسكريه ترتبط بمجموعه من
المتغيرات التي شهدناها هنا من جنوب لبنان
هذه المتغيرات ترتبط بشكل اساسي بطبيعه
الاسلحه التي بات يستخدمها حزب الله وايضا
بطبيعه العمليات التي يجري تنفيذها على
سبيل المثال اليوم نتحدث عن ست عمليات
ثلاث منها استخدم فيها حزب الله صواريخ
بركان وراسها وزنت راسها التفجيري يصل الى
نصف طن بالاضافه الى عمليه استخدم فيها
صاروخ اي اضافي وهذا الصاروخ موجه وجرى
الحديث عن بعض التفاصيل المرتبطه بمدى هذا
الصاروخ عمليا كل هذه التطورات ترتبط
بمجموعه من الرسائل التي كانت قد وصلت الى
لبنان خلال الاونه الماضيه عبر دبلوماسيين
بالاضافه الى رسائل وتهديدات اسرائيليه
بانها بان اسرائيل على وشق القيام بعمليه
عسكريه واسعه في الجنوب الليطاني وهو ما
براي كثيرين دفع الحزب الى استخدام هذه
الصواريخ سواء لناحيه صواريخ بركان او
صواريخ موجهه جرى بث بعض الفيديوهات ترتبط
بها وايضا صاروخ فلق كل هذه الصواريخ التي
جرى الكشف عنها مؤخرا ونحن نتحدث عن
الايام القليله الماضيه من الواضح وفق
محللين بان هدفها يكمن في امرين الامر
الاول هو استكمال عمليه الاسناد لقطاع غزه
من خلال هذه العمليات التي ينفذها حزب
الله هنا ولكن ايضا الامر الثاني بان هذه
الاسلحه والكشف عنها واستخدامها في
العمليات العسكر يه على طول هذا الخط
لديها هدف ثان هو هدف ردعي بمعنى انه بعد
وصول كل تلك التهديدات الاسرائيليه سواء
تلك التي تحدث عنها نتنياهو او وزير دفاعه
او رئيس الاركان الاسرائيلي عن قرب تنفيذ
عمليه في جنوب لبنان اذا لم يمتثل حزب
الله للتراجع عن الحدود وبالتالي اتاحت
عوده عشرات الاف المستوطنين الذين اجبروا
على مغادره منازلهم جراء العمليات التي
تنفذها المقاومه فان اسرائيل ستقوم بعمليه
بين الجنوب الليطاني وصولا الى الحدود
وهذا الامر كان رد الرد اللبناني واضحا
على مستويين المستوى الرسمي سواء من خلال
الكلام الذي كان قد صدر عن رئيس حكومه
تصييف الاعمال من جهه والذي اعتبر بان هذه
الجبهه لا يمكن ان تصل الى حلول منفصله
عما يحصل في غزه بالاضافه الى الكلام
الواضح الذي صدر عن حزب الله سواء من خلال
امينه العام او مجموعه من
القاد السياسيين الذين اعلنوا خلال الفتره
الماضيه بان كل هذه التهديدات الاسرائيليه
قد تؤدي الى انفلات الامور هنا لان حزب
الله مستعد لتوسيع دائره المواجهه
وبالتالي الكشف عن هذه الصواريخ هو حتما
ضمن هذه الرسائل المتبادله مع
الاسرائيليين